a roberto se le pidió determinar dónde
gtx igual a la raíz cúbica de x tienen
puntos de inflexión está su respuesta y
bien aquí tenemos tres pasos y después
nos preguntan es correcto el
procedimiento de roberto si no es así
cuál es su error
así que pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta bien vamos a
trabajarlo juntos sabemos que la función
g de x es la raíz cúbica de x déjame
ponerlo que de x es lo mismo que la raíz
cúbica de x que también lo podemos ver
como x elevado a la un tercio
y en el primer paso lo que está siendo
roberto es sacar la primera derivada y
la segunda derivada la primera derivada
se saca al usar la regla de la potencia
la primera derivada la obtengo bajando
este exponente y entonces me quedaría un
tercio que multiplica a x elevado a la
un tercio menos uno lo cual es menos dos
tercios así que la primera derivada es
correcta y después la segunda derivada
le obtengo de la siguiente manera
otra vez aplicando la regla de la
potencia como este menos dos tercios y
lo paso multiplicando a este un tercio y
me quedan menos dos novenos de x elevado
a la menos dos tercios menos uno lo cual
es menos cinco tercios y luego parece
que roberto lo reescribió de tal manera
que aquí sigo con mis menos dos novenos
y puedo reconocer que esto es lo mismo
que x elevado a las cinco tercios en el
denominador cinco tercios positivos
x elevado a las 5 tercios positivos en
el denominador es lo mismo que la raíz
cúbica de x elevado a las 5 así que todo
parece correcto
esto también es correcto y por lo tanto
puedo decir que el paso 1 es correcto de
lujo ahora en el paso 2 roberto está
buscando las soluciones en donde la
segunda derivada + sea igual a cero y en
efecto es cierto que esta igualdad no
tiene soluciones nunca puedes hacer esta
segunda derivada igual a cero entonces
eso es cierto observa para que esto
fuera igual a cero tendrías que tener el
numerador igual a cero y bueno dos nunca
será cero por lo tanto el paso 2 también
es correcto y ahora veamos el paso 3 que
no tiene puntos de inflexión esto me
parece un poco sospechoso como hemos
dicho en muchos casos los puntos de
inflexión se encuentran cuando la
segunda derivada es igual a cero e
incluso al hacer la segunda derivada
igual a cero no tenemos la certeza de
que sea un punto de inflexión
es un candidato a hacer un punto de
inflexión recuerda debes comprobar que
la segunda derivada en efecto cambie de
signo o que cruce el eje x
ya dijimos que aquí no podemos encontrar
ninguna equis que haga la segunda
derivada de igual a cero pero hay que
recordar que hay otro candidato para
nuestro punto de inflexión ese otro
candidato se encuentra cuando la segunda
derivada es indefinida y por lo tanto no
podemos hacer esta afirmación del paso 3
sin buscar en donde la segunda derivada
es indefinida así que podemos decir por
acá que
mi prima
es indefinida es decir la segunda
derivada es indefinida
cuando bueno veamos cuando que es igual
a cero cuando
x es igual a 0 porque observa 0 elevado
a la quinta potencia 0
la raíz cúbica de 0 es cero y entonces
mi denominador es cero lo que hace que
la segunda derivada sea indefinida que
es justo lo que buscamos y entonces x
igual a cero es mi candidato a hacer un
punto de inflexión entonces déjame
anotarlo eso es importante esto nos dice
que x igual a cero
un candidato a punto de inflexión
a punto de inflexión y ahora necesitamos
probar cuánto vale la segunda derivada
alrededor de él y para eso hagamos una
tabla
mi primera columna será la de intervalo
o intervalos en este caso voy a tener
dos intervalos la segunda base del valor
a probar y recuerda hay que tener
cuidado con quién será nuestro
representante en cada intervalo y
después tengo el signo de la segunda
derivada es decir el signo de javi prima
y por último pondré en la concavidad de
g
y para que el 0 sea nuestro punto de
inflexión lo que tiene que pasar es que
la segunda derivada cambie de signo en
cada uno de los intervalos que voy a
poner aquí lo que significaría que la
concavidad está cambiando en cada
intervalo nuestro primer intervalo van a
ser los números menores que 0 entonces
va a ser el intervalo de menos infinito
hasta 0 ok y el segundo intervalo van a
ser los números mayores que 0 así que va
a ser el intervalo desde cero hasta
infinito necesito un valor en cada
intervalo para probar así que voy a
tomar
como representante aquí al menos uno de
aquí al 1
recuerda que debes tener cuidado cuando
uses estos valores a probar ya que debes
estar seguro que estás lo
suficientemente cerca para que nada
inusual pase entre los valores que estás
probando y los candidatos a puntos de
inflexión en no te vayas a confundir de
intervalo bien y ahora cuál es el signo
de la segunda derivada bueno cuál es el
signo de la segunda derivada cuando x es
igual a menos 1 aquí me quedarían menos
una elevado a la quinta potencia lo cual
es menos 1 y por lo tanto tendremos la
raíz cúbica de menos 1 lo cual también
es menos 1 y entonces me quedan menos
dos novenos que está dividido por menos
uno lo cual es dos novenos positivos por
lo tanto mi signo en el primer intervalo
será positivo y de hecho para cualquier
número que te tomes en este primer
intervalo el signo de la segunda
derivada va a ser positivo observa un
número negativo elevado a la quinta
potencia es un número negativo y la raíz
cúbica de un número negativo es también
un número negativo y después menos dos
novenos entre un número negativo me va a
dar un número
por lo tanto el signo de la segunda
derivada en el primer intervalo ya
podemos asegurar que es positivo bien
pensamos que pasa en el segundo
intervalo si tomó cualquier número
positivo voy a obtener aquí un número
positivo elevado a la quinta potencia lo
cual será positivo la raíz cúbica de un
número positivo es positivo y después
menos dos novenos entre un número
positivo me va a dar algo negativo por
lo tanto ya tengo los signos de mi
segunda derivada así que en efecto
estamos en el caso donde nuestra segunda
derivada cambiar de signo cuando
cruzamos el valor de x igual a cero es
más déjeme anotar lo que vi prima cambia
de signo cuando cruzamos el valor de que
es igual a cero y además la función no
está definida en x igual a cero eso es
importante entonces voy a escribir que
gm está definida en x igual a cero ok y
eso nos está diciendo que la concavidad
en el primer intervalo es una concavidad
asia
déjame ponerlo esto porque si no en la
segunda derivada es positivo y tenemos
una concavidad hacia abajo déjame
ponerlo
en el segundo intervalo porque el signo
de mi segunda derivada es negativo y
entonces esto todo esto nos está
diciendo que en efecto tenemos un punto
de inflexión en x igual a 0 entonces
déjame ponerlo
x igual a 0 es un punto de inflexión y
si estás familiarizado con la función de
la raíz cúbica de x podrás ver que en
efecto tienes un punto de inflexión en x
igual a 0 así que ya podemos concluir el
procedimiento de roberto fue erróneo
tuvo un error en el paso 3 ya que si
existe un punto de inflexión el cual no
hace la segunda derivada de igual a 0
pero es un punto en donde la segunda
derivada es indefinida así que hemos
terminado espero que lo hayas disfrutado